penelope jackson had just stabbed her
husband david
three times
police recording her arrest
think he could be saved
get the ambulance in pronto
no no no
david jackson had called 999 he was
heard screaming a call handler asked his
wife to stop
she didn't
and are you with him now
well i might just go and stab him again
all right do not stab him again
so okay so in total how many times
oh three times three times
once i thought i'd get his heart well we
haven't got one and then
twice in the abdomen
penelope jackson claimed that david had
been coercive and controlling during
their 24 years of marriage she said he
would strangle her to the point of
unconsciousness and shake and kick her
he's an aggressive bully and nasty
and i've had
enough and when he said
you wouldn't do it or did it twice more
in february during the winter lockdown
jackson said she'd lost the plot after
david called her pathetic
she wrote a note of confession signing
off that she accepted her punishment may
he rot in hell
there was no reaction from penelope
jackson as the jury of eight women and
four men found her guilty of murder but
she wiped away tears as the court heard
how the couple's only daughter had lost
the man she looked up to
and
loved another family member told the
court that it was david who was the real
victim of domestic violence and
sentencing his wife to 18 years in
prison the judge said he had seen no
remorse
i stabbed him
and had no doubt that david was nothing
like the person she'd claimed
lisa dowd sky news bristol